[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce 7 8 dossiers un rendez vous proposés
par la rédaction de tv fil 78
tous les mois nous décryptons une
thématique à travers une série de
reportages et aujourd'hui nous partons à
la découverte de profession méconnue
l'institut national des métiers d'art
recense quelques 1400 savoir faire rare
parmi eux la dorure la lutherie la
ferronnerie d'art ou encore le
garnissage de marteau de piano nous
avons rencontré des artisans et des
entrepreneurs spécialisés dans ces
activités artisanales dans les yvelines
et pour débuter direction montigny le
bretonneux mehdi mallié a créé son
atelier de ferronnerie d'art il ya 25
ans je vous propose de regarder
[Musique]
650 heures de travail artisanal pour ce
meuble destiné à un client américain
une pièce en métal pesant près d'une
tonne on a une structure merck et en
tubes et après c'est des habillages avec
beaucoup de fer plat beaucoup de tôles
découpées laser et son fond vissé avec
davis bombe et poussa docteur
l'entreprise dunod mallié participe à la
sauvegarde de cette activité artisanale
la ferronnerie d'art un savoir-faire
basée sur la maîtrise du fer et de la
métallerie fille créé en 1995 cette
société comptabilise 15 salariés dont
deux dessinateurs un chef d'atelier et
des ouvriers de production
on fabrique des pièces uniques on
fabrique des rampes d'escalier un petit
peu atypique avec ce que ça c'est le
coeur du métier quand même de ce qu'on
appelle le débardage quelque chose
d'assez qui est en voie de disparition
pour le coup tous les métaux sont mis à
contribution pour des rampes d'escalier
classique jusqu'à des projets
exceptionnels
c'est le cas pour un client russe au
total il a fallu dix mille heures de
travail
cette trempe là qu'on a fait à moscou
j'en parle tout le temps parce que ça
une pièce exceptionnelle de ferronnerie
après des projets fous là on fait des
portes en cuivre pour qu'ils vont partir
en australie
ça reste très artisanal il n'y a pas en
fait nous on n'a pas de plus value sur
l'achat matière sur ses pas là où où la
rentabilité de l'entreprise se fait
c'est vraiment sur le taux horaire
la revente d'un savoir-faire donc du
coup on passe énormément de temps sur
les pièces en centaines d'heures chaque
pièce des centaines d'heures dunod
mallié mise sur la ferronnerie du luxe
son chiffre d'affaires près d'un million
cinq cent mille euros avec une
progression de 10% par an sur ces cinq
dernières années 70 % de l'activité se
fait à l'export pour trouver de la main
d'oeuvre la société pioche dans les
réseaux des compagnons du tour de france
beaucoup de jeunes conforme en interne
après bien sûr le réseau des compagnons
parce que quand même une école entre
guillemets une école
d'excellence alors après l'évolution du
métier je la connais pas trop quoi c'est
des choses des sujets auxquels je pense
de temps en temps c'est à dire est ce
que dans 20 ans on aura encore besoin
dans un d'un ferronnier
je ne sais pas encore métier rare la
ferronnerie d'art aurait de l'avenir
malgré la mutation industrielle dans les
yvelines d'après midi mallié ils sont
moins de cinq ateliers spécialisés dans
cette activité
[Musique]
le feutre est au piano ce que le pneu
est à la voiture patrick des fougères et
garnisseur de marteau le seul en france
avec un savoir-faire très spécifique
transmis depuis 1925 un feu peut
résister 30 ans pour des particuliers et
5 ans pour des professionnels suivants
comme on joue comme les pneumatiques
comment conduit donc abandonné va le feu
tu es trop dur ou trop mou ou la
son il est mort vers la structure
interne du feutre et est morte
donc faut le regarder et tout ça ça là
bas ont dégarni et ont regardé un feutre
s'adorent va dégainer un ancien feu pour
gardien avec un nouveau photo comme son
père avant lui patrick reprend la sphère
familiale dans les années 90 il
s'installe à la verrière en 2007 avec
ses deux salariés en position de
monopole sur le marché européen il
s'exporte aussi en russie aux etats-unis
ou en australie
avec un réseau de près de 1000 clients
il ya des gens qu'on va revoir souvent
d'autres on va voir une fois tous les
ans une fois tous les dix ans il ya des
nouveaux qui arrivent c'est un marché de
collectionneurs de passionnés faut
savoir que j'ai des concurrents mais qui
font dans l'industrie lourde arctique
qui créent et qui fabrique des têtes 9
pour la première monte ou la seconde
monte des pianos malherbe donc toujours
petit marché à cette petite niche mais
vu qu'on est salée certain savoir faire
on est clairement unique donc bah ça ça
fait vivre quand même l'entreprise
j'oserais boulot c'est un regard ni
soeur de marteau de canaux pour les
intérieurs 20 30 et aussi avant les
cadeaux parce qu'elle dollars et 4 forte
et piano
des pianos présence grâce à leur
technicité les ateliers des fougères ont
obtenu le label d'état entreprise du
patrimoine vivant
on en reste traditionnelle dans notre
savoir faire par contre on sait de
choses modernes pour pour améliorer au
niveau tant au niveau qualité ou vos
tensions parle des fautes mais faut de
la tension donc un bandana une certaine
tension ça c'est quand machine
donc on reçoit des le jeu partout comme
ça ça fait tout un jeu de marteau ont
dégarni à la main ou à la vapeur là dans
ce cas là c'est à la main on va mettre
tout ce jeu là qui est devant moi sur ce
porte marteau et décale avec des séracs
imprécises des gabarits alors mais la
bande là le jeu de marteau dans son
porte marteau ici et ça va descendre ici
mais il possède ses petits secrets de
production et forme lui même sa main
d'oeuvre
patrick serait le dernier des des
fougères à exercer cette activité
ces enfants ne s'étant pas accordé à la
voix artisanale
[Musique]
c'est un instrument de musique créé en
italie au xvième siècle le théorbe gens
de manger à fabriquer celui-ci de ses
propres mains avec 14 corde pour un prix
de vente autour des 2500 euros ceci est
un terme avec les corps sur le manche et
six cordes sur l'extérieur qui sont les
coeurs passe le manche est notamment
beaucoup plus lents tels que sur un luth
classique
c'est la forme d'un luth bien sûr on
peut pas dire le contraire mais
il ya une prolongation
au niveau 2 au niveau de la tête son
activité créée redonner vie aux
instruments de musique à cordes violon
guitare ou contrebasse un métier entre
art et artisanat apparu au tout début du
xvième siècle cette passion jean de
manger la débuté en 1973 avec sa
boutique à versailles
si jamais rêvé de l'ébénisterie je veux
dire qu'en matière de membres ont jeté
un truc de cabine qui magasin entrailles
faisait des guitares jeu
le luthier restaure façonnent les voûtes
et pose les vernis de résine en
savoir-faire exigeant qui nécessite
aussi bien une solide connaissance des
différents matériaux d'une grande
culture technique et historique et
surtout beaucoup de persévérance
quand on enseigne un truc comme ça
cd suite après après l'enseignement que
la personne a
le métier en main deux tours de trouver
des possibilités de s'installer cetera
et cetera
heureusement le métier de moins bien la
lutherie c'est un métier où il faut être
sur le tas pour pouvoir le savoir et le
connaître
on n'apprend pas un métier comme ça en
cinq ans - besoin pour dix ans
il faut 20 ans ou 30 ans pour avoir vécu
depuis qu'il est à la retraite jean de
manger vite à coignières est à 74 ans il
ne compte pas abandonner sa vocation
[Musique]
il faut avoir l'oreille musicale et
c'est pas forcément il nécessité d'être
musicien
le principal site a accordé un soin si
longtemps que j'ai ma tête et mes doigts
le métier mon métier c'est magique
selon un recensement plus de 400 luthier
était en exercice en 2009
un amour du bois et de la musique qui
traverse les siècles
tout comme ces instruments
[Musique]
de fines feuilles d'or très fragile
comme matériaux de production
marlène voisin est artisan d'horreur
elle travaille sur un cadran siens après
l'avoir redimensionner elle peut
commencer à le doré donc on utilise le
souffle le couteau et des petits
pinceaux
vous avez la palette qui en poils de
martre et puis les petits pinceaux en
petits gris me servir à appuyer la
feuille d'or ça c'est que de l'eau c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle ça une dorure à la
détrempe parce que notre support lui
qu'on a appliqué est à base de colle
donc quand on vient l'humidifier sarah
vit de la colle cela colle de peau de
lapin et du coup quand ça sèche et ben
ça tient arrivé en 2008 à versailles
pour ouvrir son atelier l'artisan à la
dorure dans la main depuis son
adolescence j'ai commencé j'avais 15 ans
quand je me suis mis à à m'orienter là
dedans
donc c'est un apprentissage qui dure sur
trois ans max et à peut-être de doreur
plus du recel arrive à trouver un
formateur en fait quelqu'un qui veuille
bien nous former parce qu'on n'est pas
de trop avec un chiffre d'affaires de 55
mille euros marlène s'appuie sur des
clients connaisseurs autres facteurs
faisant la rareté de ce métier les prix
élevés les clients sont assez fidèles
puissent et des métiers bon on n'est pas
nombreux donc en fait c'est beaucoup de
bouche à oreille aussi après on
travaille aussi pour des
musée des hôtels particuliers des
professionnels aussi
donc dans l'ensemble je pense qu'on va
être 150 200 à peu près à tourner sur
plusieurs années pour obtenir une dorure
de qualité toutes les étapes sont
importantes cadres miroirs ou boiseries
marlène travail plusieurs objets datant
du 16e au 20e siècle
sa restauration la plus marquante une
table de gibier d'époque louis xiv
les gens viennent avec leurs cadres leur
glace donc repositionne de la feuille
d'or dedans c'est un métier qui n'a pas
changé vos à des techniques par rapport
au xviie xviiie siècle on utilise les
mêmes techniques les mêmes produits
tout est artisanal en fait pour ce cadre
sculptés en bois du xviiie siècle
l'artisan démontre sa polyvalence est
essentielle dans l'exercice de son
activité
on vient faire tout un travail de
ponçage et de re parures avec les petits
faire pour redonner toutes les nervures
de la sculpture malgré sa rareté la
dorure perdure à travers les siècles et
les techniques avec notamment grâce à la
transmission du savoir faire
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
le site internet de tv fil 78 ou sur
notre application mobile à très bientôt
[Musique]